At this point let's turn to an overview of our immune system to help us
understand exactly what's happening in our bodies and our ability to fight off
illnesses. There are two types of defense we have as humans, we have natural
immunity and we have acquired immunity. Natural immunity refers to the
processes that we have to remove foreign substances from our bodies.
Inflammation, and phagocytosis, are two forms of natural immunity. Inflammation
occurs when tissues are restored following some type of injury. Where as
phagocytosis occurs when white blood cells take in a substance, and digest it,
or, move it to a place where it can be destroyed. So these are two types of
natural immunities. And we have acquired immunities when we get antibodies that
are produced in the body in response to specific antigens. We get these through
experience. For example, when you become sick from a virus, you develop
antibodies that defend against that virus. And that's why specific viruses
cannot affect you again in the future. This is an example of an acquired
immunity.